when you present this you say well
actually this mostly isn't the fetus
this mostly is all this other stuff okay
but then you're not showing me what a
fetus looks like the fetus is in this
picture right but just very very small
that is how so how much of that picture
is the fetus it is indistinguishable to
the human eye oh so so now all you're
saying is the fetus at that stage it's
not that uh
it's not that the fetus you know looks
like all this tissue actually isn't
really the fetus because you you can't
even see the feet exactly but you can't
really see it so now you're what you're
admitting is you're not showing people a
picture of a fetus you're showing people
a picture of a gestational Sac that's
been expelled with a tiny fetus if you
wanted to show people what a fetus looks
like at the age of 10 weeks in gestation
you would show them the fetus itself and
you'd have to zoom in because it's very
time you would have to use a microscope
you know this is the year of Our Lord
2022 we have plenty of medical
Technologies which are being put to
Great evil but we we can also put them
to good use and show what the baby looks
like and it is simply a fact at 10 weeks
the baby looks like a baby